dans ce magnifique endroit qui est à la
fois chargé d'histoire et qui me permet
aussi d'être au travail en regardant le
futur et le futur l'union européenne en
particulier dans un moment qui est un
moment difficile parce que nous sommes
confrontés à une guerre qui frappe le
continent européen ces déclarations de
versailles qui a été approuvé
formellement il ya quelques instants
restera dans les annales du projet
européen elle restera nous avons des
projets européens parce que nous avons
depuis quelques temps compris et
considérer que l'on devait engager un
agenda de souveraineté un agenda
d'autonomie stratégique pour l'union
européenne qui se traduit au travers
notre ambition de prendre en
considération les forces les atouts le
ciment qui rassemble un européen mais de
regarder aussi tels sont les points de
fragilité telle onde a tenté de corriger
quels sont les points qu'il faut tenter
de renforcer et cette réunion de
versailles intervient à un moment où la
russie il ya deux semaines a déclenché
une guerre contre l'ukraine il ya un
moment où depuis deux semaines l'union
européenne a démontré son humilité sa
robustesse sa solidité nous avons été
capables de nous rassembler pour décider
des sanctions sans précédent qui ont un
impact qui ont un effet nous avons des
cas pas d'une rassemblés pour soutenir
fortement le peuple ukrainien qui se bat
avec courage
soutien sur le plan financier sur le
plan humanitaire soutien bien sûr en
terme d'accueil des réfugiés soutient
aussi c'est une première qui étaient
décidées et qui traduit l'ambition
d'agir seuls pour la défense européenne
au travers de la facilité paix qui
mobilise du matériel y compris
militaires et l'orientation a été prise
d'ajouter 500 millions d'euros
additionnels à la facilité paix dans ce
cadre quand vous le voyez nous sommes
engagés sur le terrain du soutien à
l'ukraine nous avons eu bien sûr un
débat sur la demande qui a été
introduite par l'ukraine même demande a
été introduite par la géorgie et la
moldavie nous voulons dire avec
solennité avec force à nos amis
ukrainiens qu'ils sont bien entendu
pleinement membres de la famille
européenne et nous voulons leur dire que
nous allons nous engager et nous
mobiliser rapidement immédiatement pour
renforcer les liens avec le peuple
ukrainien et nous allons en clip
d'engager pour soutenir et supporter le
choix qu'ils font pour ce chemin
européen enfin nous avons eu l'occasion
bien sûr de débattre beaucoup de la
manière d'engager l'europe de cet agenda
de souveraineté et de tony stratégie
lurel très simplement détruire
rapidement les trois piliers
au départ aujourd'hui dans cette
déclaration avec force avec solennité
une regardons vers l'avenir pour tenter
de donner un élan à ce projet européen
un élan de robustesse un élan engagé
d'une part bien sûr la question de
l'énergie et nous ne découvrons pas
aujourd'hui cet enjeu de l'énergie
seigneur le sens de la décision que nous
avions prise d'engager la neutralité
climat à l'horizon 2050 pour faire en
sorte que l'on puisse progresser sur le
terrain de notre indépendance tout en
adressant le défi climat est il ya trois
points qui sont importants et que nous
voulons traiter bien entendu la question
des prix et de l'impact pour les
familles partout en europe a pas de
point les familles intactes nos
entreprises également la question de la
dépendance la dépendance qui est trop
grande on le voit bien aujourd'hui
singulièrement face à la russie pour
lequel nous voulons développer cette
ambition nous libérer de cette
dépendance pour avoir une capacité
d'agir au mieux et conformément à nos
intérêts et cela en accord avec nos
objectifs et puis en fin de rencontre
est opérationnel et l'engagement pour un
plan pour le prochain hiver et sur
chacun de ces points là en parfaite
synchronisation conseil européen est un
membre avec la commission qui est
chargée de préparer la suite de nos
travaux et des décisions que nous
prendrons tous ces sujets là c'est un
agenda cohérent qui est préparé et qui
est engagée le deuxième point c'est bien
sûr la question de la défense et de la
sécurité mais lors de la défense
nous sommes nombreux à en parler depuis
longtemps des progrès ont pu être
réalisés il est indéniable que il ya
deux semaines nous sommes réveillés dans
une europe différente dans un monde
différent il est indéniable des actions
qui ont été entreprises ces derniers
jours en réalité consacre l'année sans
la défense européenne qui est
formellement engagé avec cette réunion
aujourd'hui ici à versailles pour lequel
là aussi on engage une stratégie très
opérationnelle c'est lisa identifier
quels sont les champs d'actions et
d'investissements qui vont être
nécessaires mais identifie aussi comment
dit on peut déployer une base
industrielle européenne en prenant en
considération différents enjeux l'enjeu
de la cybersécurité est l'enjeu de
l'espace par exemple en citer
quelques-uns nous allons donc là aussi
avec un calendrier un agenda avec une
mission qui est confiée à la commission
et au fonds de défense veiller à
progresser sur ce sujet des pluies enfin
le troisième point la fête mentionné
c'est l'importance de consolider cette
base ethnique l'union européenne est
bien sûr un projet de rassemblement pour
la paix la sécurité et pour la
prospérité c'est bien sûr un projet et
une unité dans cette dimension là il il
appartient il appartient à notre
génération de prendre aujourd'hui des
décisions qui vont rendre cette base
économique robuste plus solide plus
résiliente et c'est le sens de nos
engagements en termes de santé lequel il
avait montré l'importance de coordonner
davantage l'importance de projeter
d'inventaire l'année ce sujet la selle
sens aussi de l'ambition liées aux
semi-conducteurs par exemple aux
matières premières aux matériaux
critique ou bien à l'impérieuse
nécessité de continuer à être très
engagée sur le plan de l'innovation
singulièrement de l'innovation en
technologie toi là en quelques en
quelques mots le sens des décisions que
je crois très fortes qui ont été prises
aujourd'hui avait une grande conscience
partagée par l'ensemble des vidéos
européen rassemble ici à versailles une
grande conscience partagée de
l'importance du moment que nous vivons
et de l'importance des décisions que
nous allons prendre pas seulement pour
demain ou après demain mais pour les
générations qui vont nous suivre il
s'agit de venir au fondement de ce
projet qui a rassemblé l'union
européenne la paix la prospérité
la sécurité
et ce sont ces enjeux là que nous
voulons embrasser afin de faire en sorte
que des résultats tangibles des
résultats concrets perceptible en termes
de plus d'indépendance de plus de
souveraineté de moi de fragilité et de
plus de capacité à les terminer nous
mêmes quel est le destin que nous
voulons pour l'union européenne enfin
nous aurons l'occasion de revenir très
rapidement dans l'implémentation dont la
mise en oeuvre de l'ensemble des sujets
il y aura dans deux semaines un conseil
européen qui se tiendra à bruxelles
reviendront par exemple des questions
énergétiques et sur d'autres sujets nous
avons aussi l'intention
avant le sommet prévu au mois de juin
d'avoir un sommet européen
extraordinaire sera également l'occasion
de revenir ça a dû lui remet en question
de sécurité et donnent et de défense
encore une fois je souhaite remercier le
prénom macron pour nous avoir rassemblé
ici à versailles dans un moment qui est
chargé de symbole dans un moment qui
touchent à l'histoire de ce pays à
l'histoire de l'europe également et à un
moment au cours duquel hier et
aujourd'hui nous avons fait le choix de
nous rassembler nous serrer les coudes
pour faire en sorte que l'on puisse
porter ce rêve et cette ambition pour
l'avenir de l'europe je remercie
merci charles merci manuel marcy de nous
recevoir ici dans un lieu tellement
chargé d'histoire
car c'est bien l'avenir de l'ukraine et
l'histoire à venir de l'union européenne
et de nos démocraties
qui s'écrit en ce moment
car de fait nos destins sont liés
l'ukraine fait partie de la famille
européenne
l'agression de poutine contre l'ukraine
est une agression contre tous les
principes qui nous sont chères c'est une
attaque contre les démocraties contre la
souveraineté des états contre la liberté
d'un peuple de choisir son destin est de
façonner son avenir
la façon dont nous répondons aujourd'hui
à l'odieuse attaque de la russie contre
l'ukraine va déterminer tant l'avenir de
l'ukraine que celui de notre union et
même au delà du continent européen
alors restant fidèle aux principes qui
ont guidé jusqu'ici notre réponse
commune c'est la responsabilité c'est
l'unité c'est la solidarité et c'est la
détermination
risque rail ce samedi 8 mai la crise à
toi responsibilities
infiniti
à
shanghai